der nächste teil der eignungsprüfung
heißt company which und dabei wird seine
sprungkraft getestet das training ist
für mich natürlich dass alle und ich
möchte dir erklären und zeigen wie man
die sprungkraft für die eignungsprüfung
am besten trainiert und verbessern kann
zu beginn des tests wird die strecke
gemessen
dazu stehst du mit gestreckten armen vor
einer wand dann springst du hoch und
versuchst am höchsten punkt die zweite
markierung zu machen
die differenz zwischen den beiden
punkten ist dann deine sprunghöhe der
eignungsprüfung hast du drei versuche
der höchste fehlt und die maximale höhe
zu erreichen die erst in die knie folge
wohl mit den armen kräftig schwung und
mit dieser vorspannung springst du dann
ab beachte auch das richtige timing
versetzen der zweiten markierung das
jetzt einfach übungssache
wichtig ist dass du dich nicht verletzt
so dass du beim landen nicht ex oder ob
ein kauf kommst
zum glück gibt es beim tempo nützt es
keine haltungsnoten es ist mir wichtig
dass man sicher landet aber es ist sehr
wichtig dass wir die übung zu hause
trainiert und das funktioniert sehr
super mir dann klebte comedy übung super
trainieren und nur so landet musik beim
herr